alors comme vous pouvez le voir autour
de moi c'est un travail d'équipé que
nous avons menées et dans ce cadre je
tiens à remercier chacune et chacun
d'entre vous monsieur le président alain
ramadier les députés présents et absents
mais qui ont contribué à cette mission
les administrateurs de l'assemblée
nationale pour leur remarquable travail
sans lequel nous ne serions pas réunis
aujourd'hui et évidemment toutes les
personnes qui se sont mobilisées qui se
mobilisent encore autour de ce dossier
que représente l'aide sociale à
l'enfance notamment toutes les personnes
que nous avons auditionné cette mission
d'information concerne les 341 milles
enfants pris en charge par l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
nous en parlons bien là et ce sont bien
les enfants dont nous parlons et c'est
là notre responsabilité
ce rapport malheureusement n'est pas une
première et je crains que ce ne soit pas
une fin non plus et malheureusement je
le regrette
c'est juste une nouvelle étape pour
trouver ensemble les bonnes solutions
dans l'intérêt des enfants et surtout de
les mettre en application
j'y serai et nous y serons très
attentive et attentifs et nous serons
intransigeants
bien entendu cette mission vous le savez
fait suite un travail personnel que j'ai
mené durant 18 mois et à cette mission
d'information se sont joints à moi 22
députés de toutes tendances confondues
qui m'ont accompagné pendant ces trois
derniers mois
par ce travail collectif trente trois
auditions ont été menées et 18
propositions accompagné de nombreuses
suggestions que nous vous présentons que
nous vous présentons aujourd'hui nous
vous avons tenté de mener une étude
approfondie sur les résultats de cette
petite de l'aide sociale à l'enfance et
d'y apporter de vraies réponses avec
comme seul primauté faire de ses enfants
une priorité absolue qu'ils soient au
coeur de nos préoccupations afin de leur
donner un véritable avenir voire
l'égalité des chances qui est un
principe fondateur de notre république
notre travail n'a pas eu pour vocation
d'émettre une opinion mais bien
d'éclairer cette politique parfois
dépassés pour lui permettre un
changement et des prises de décision
rapides en 2018
341 milles mesures de protection ont été
prononcées dont 52 % concernent des
placements mais les résultats de cette
politique reste me laisse perplexe à
l'école lieu au comme un précieux
on se rend compte que deux tiers des
enfants placés ont au moins un an de
retard à leur entrée en 6e à 17 ans 23%
des enfants de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ne sont plus scolarisés 5%
d'entre seulement suivent un cycle
général ou technologique de lycées
contre 49% pour le reste de la
population
à 17 ans les jeunes femmes qui sont
allées de sociale à l'enfance ont treize
fois plus de risques d'être enceinte que
la population normale
30% des utilisateurs des services
d'hébergement temporaire et de
restauration gratuite
né en france où il est en arrivé avant
18 ans sont des anciens enfants de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance et tout le
monde connaît ce chiffre mais je tiens à
le rappeler
25% des sans domicile fixe de moins de
25 ans en france ont été placés en foyer
ou en famille d'accueil
je tiens également à inciter un passage
du 24e rapport de la fondation abbé
pierre sur le mal-logement qui démontre
la difficulté pérenne de ses enfants
lorsqu'ils sont mal accompagné parmi les
personnes qui ont connu la rue après
l'aide sociale à l'enfance 21% l'inconnu
moins d'un an après leur sortie et 39%
l'on subit plus de dix ans après ce qui
montre bien les difficultés pérenne de
ses enfants qui sont passés par l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
tous ces éléments m'ont amené bien
entendu à demander une mission
d'information et je tiens à ce titre a
remercié le président de l'assemblée
nationale et la conférence des
présidents d'avoir pris la mesure et la
gravité de ce sujet et d'avoir créé une
mission d'information de la présidence
le 5 mars dernier
l'aide sociale à l'enfance vous le savez
une politique décentralisée porté par
les conseils départementaux
ils doivent apporter un soutien matériel
l éducatif et psychologique tant aux
mineurs qu'à leurs familles confrontées
à des difficultés qui risque de mettre
en danger la santé la sécurité la
moralité de ces mineurs ou de
compromettre gravement leur éducation
leur développement physique affectif
intellectuel et social les départements
consacre un budget conséquent à l'aide
sociale en france
une évaluation est de 8 milliards
d'euros en augmentation constante et qui
exclue malheureusement le département de
mayotte qui est toujours traité à part
et bien entendu hors masse salariale et
on constate par rapport à ces
départements une forte disparité
certains département consacre 5 % de
leur budget à l'aide sociale enfance
quand d'autres portent leurs efforts à
20%
ça reste interrogeant les départements
le choix ils peuvent gérer l'aide
sociale à l'enfance directement en régie
ou avec le concours d'établissement et
de professionnels dûment habilités mais
la décentralisation engendre autant de
politique sociale l'aide à l'enfance
qu'il existe deux départements nous
constatons également des variabilités de
coûts des mesures de l'aide sociale en
france par exemple le prix moyen d'une
journée en famille d'accueil en france
et 200 euros
il est seulement 2 48 euros dans les
alpes maritimes ou encore le prix d'une
journée d'action éducative en milieu
ouvert varie de 8 à 20 euros tout ceci
peut altérer la prise en charge de
l'enfant
en bref 101 départements sans une
politique dette sociale
ce n'est pas et ce n'est plus acceptable
l'aide sociale à l'enfance c'est
également une multitude d'acteurs qui
interagissent la justice éducation
nationale les professionnels de santé
l'administration centrale ou encore la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
mais c'est aussi des organismes
nationaux le giped le cnp eu l'audace
l'agencé française d'adoption le hcf ea
et j'en oublie sûrement
mais je suis forcé de constater que le
pilotage est trop rare entre ses acteurs
l'état va donc reprendre une place
majeure dans cette politique que je
considère comme étant régaliennes c'est
pourquoi je souhaite la création d'une
agence nationale de protection de
l'enfance qui serait co piloté par
l'état et les départements
afin d'assurer une application homogène
de la politique d' aide sociale à
l'enfance en france nous souhaitons dans
ce cadre la nomination auprès de chaque
préfet d'un délégué référant à la
protection de l'enfance comme il existe
un délégué à l'égalité femme homme ou un
délégué à la politique de la ville tout
ça pour coordonner le pilotage
départemental de cette politique tout au
long de notre travail on raisonnait en
nou lé témoignage courageux et
bouleversants des anciens enfants
confiés à l'aide sociale en france que
nous avons entendu pendant leur audition
je tiens une nouvelle fois les remercier
pour leur aide et leur contribution au
travail de cette mission car nous ont
apporté plusieurs suggestions notamment
nous rappelons que le passage devant un
juge est une épreuve difficile pour
cette raison nous souhaitons rendre
obligatoire la présence d'un avocat
auprès de cheikh enfants parce qu une
mesure éducative ou de placement est
envisagée et bien entendu cet avocat
seraient pris en charge par l'aide
juridictionnelle
enfin la politique doit être sociale
enfance doit permettre à ces enfants
d'avoir les mêmes chances que les autres
à ce titre deux points doivent être
améliorer la santé et la scolarité
chaque enfant de l'aide sociale en
france doit dès le premier mois de
placement bénéficier d'un bilan de santé
complet de lui apporter si besoin un
suivi psychologique
tout au long de son parcours en
permettant d'avoir accès à des
professionnels de ville
quand les cmp et les cambistes sont
engorgés voir déborder
enfin chaque enfant a droit à ce que
l'arrêté digne et de choisir son
parcours
trop d'enfants sont déscolarisés nous
devons donc nommé en urgence des
professeurs des écoles dans les
structures d'accueil d'urgence
mon intervention voulait compris n'est
pas exhaustive je vous invite à lire et
bien attentivement notre rapport mais
surtout et 18 propositions un exemplaire
va vous en êtes remis d'une synthèse et
vous trouverez le rapport de manière
complète sur le site de l'assemblée
nationale
et je tiens à vous dire que je serai
mais après l'adoption à l'unanimité de
ce rapport tout à l'heure en commission
je pense que nous pouvons dire nous
serons vigilants et intransigeant quant
à la prise en compte des recommandations
que nous faisons
car compte tenu et vous le savez ça
c'est plus personnel de mon passé il est
difficile
pour moi de constater que 20 ans après
des enfants subissent toujours les mêmes
violences les mêmes manque
d'accompagnement et de considération
désormais nous devons en france mettre
l'enfant au coeur du triangle état
département sociétés et porter cette
ambition également à l'échelle
européenne notamment pour les
difficultés rencontrées par les mineurs
non accompagnés
je vous remercie de votre écoute pour
cette introduction et nous restons
disponibles pour vos questions